what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to tick tock being proud
of obesity before i start don't forget
to subscribe to the channel and ring
that notification bell that way you're
going to be notified of my daily videos
also if you have watched three or more
of my videos hit that subscribe button
otherwise we have beef okay i'm making
this content for you guys
out of the kindness of my heart hit that
subscribe button it'll take you a second
one second powerful in this world
there's nothing more powerful in this
world
than a fat [ __ ]
who is unapologetically confident
hi
i'm that fat [ __ ] okay um let's start
with the word powerful when you think of
powerful
you think of someone that's like strong
right
now clearly
if you're overweight
you're not
strong to the point you can be like
lifting like
lifting things and i don't know
partaking in powerful activities
um
on top of that i don't think people care
if you're confident to be honest
i'm not saying that if you're overweight
you should just sit there and hate your
life and wallow in it but
if you're confident and you're
overweight cool i don't care
like nobody's thinking about you that
much
this is what i eat in a day as a fat
person that isn't trying to lose weight
let's see so first i started off with
some iced coffee it was delicious then i
have some eggs they were really good too
and i had a piece of toast with some
butter and jam on it i thought the jam
would cover up the burness but it did
not it was nasty
i had a banana it's a banana it's
average then i had a mcdouble and small
fry for lunch it was pretty good it's
mcdonald's you know
then for a drink i had starbucks and it
was so good oh my gosh i have been
weeding myself off of starbucks the past
couple of months i still i still cave
every now and then but i've been weeding
myself off of it and i've seen such a
difference in
my energy levels surprisingly and my
weight loss it like the weight that i
was trying to lose and working so hard
to lose just started to come off
when i added starbucks or got rid of
starbucks
at work they had some breadsticks so i
had to snag one although it was dry as
hell so i had to drink some water
um for dinner i had some taco bell i had
a bean burrito then i had a baja blast
freeze
um i almost choked right there
i saw my life flash before my eyes
and also if anybody says anything about
my pimple you're being blocked okay bye
ten years ago to be honest i mean that
was bad it had fast food pure sugar
it was bad but
for how big she was i was expecting
worse to be honest i decided that i
didn't want to hit my body and in the
process of doing that i started a
fashion blog okay
i hate my body a little bit i i'm i
don't go around thinking i'm obese but i
hate it a little bit and i've hated it a
little bit for a long time
and that my friends is why i can
deadlift 300 pounds
is because i hate my body
enough to keep going to the gym yup
don't be too confident
that is the end of your weight loss
journey let me tell you that turned
my body and who i am into my career my
business um so i believe in exposure
therapy exposure therapy it was the
first time i had worn a swimsuit skirt
dresses um and even though it's been 10
years of this process there's still
certain things that scare me to this day
and one of the things is seeing my body
when i'm sitting down
and so i believe in exposure therapy so
i'm gonna film my body sitting down so
if you're out there you're a fat person
um and you're like oh i hate my
reflection i hate seeing myself sitting
down i'm doing it you can do it there's
no shame
why don't we just
and i'm saying this out of love right i
don't want people that are overweight to
sit there and just hate themselves but
you're going to feel a million times
better if you change your lifestyle
you're going to feel a million times
better
if you hit the gym
and that's going to contribute more to
your confidence
than taking a video of you sitting down
like okay our bodies are normal um so
yeah let me film that right now but it's
not normal
and that's that's us women we tell each
other things we want to hear
to make each other feel better
i don't know i am this is my body
sitting down and i know that it makes me
in a room do you think she would be
normal
or do you think she'd be one of the
biggest ones i remember any given 10
people comfortable seeing like my poop
on my stomach all together but it's okay
it's normal it's a body and i just want
to get to the point where it's just a
neutral feeling for me um so exposure
therapy
random things i noticed after gaining 40
pounds as always this series is not
meant to encourage or discourage weight
loss or weight gain of any kind it's
just a collection of different
observations i happen to make part two i
grew out of a lot of my clothes but not
in the way you would think see it's not
as easy as just buying the same pair of
pants in a bigger size because pants
that used to be too big for my waist and
too small for my butt are now too small
for my waist and too big for my butt
because in case you didn't know you
don't always gain weight evenly for me
personally i really only gained it in my
upper hemisphere so trying to find new
clothes is more oh my gosh that's how i
am when i gain weight it's my stomach
and my arms i don't really gain weight
in my legs i would not be
an attractive fat person
some people
i don't want to say they're more
attractive bigger but
they don't look bad
big
if that makes sense because of where
they gain the weight that's easier than
you would think
[Music]
oh dear what is she doing
[Music]
things that make me nervous as a fat
girl
i want to go clothes shopping plastic
chairs seat belts
seat belt oh my gosh i didn't even think
about that
[Music]
clothes
[Music]
[ __ ] oh
oh
oh my gosh i thought that was
oh dear okay
open the fridge then i eat all the
snacks drink all the soda then i burp
like that dang i'll be wondering why i
fart like that why i smell like that
while i'm shaped like that
okay the woman who should get the only
woman who should get out of the kitchen
[Music]
[ __ ] what's the worst thing that's
gonna happen if you start believing that
you're the hottest [ __ ] alive someone
tells you that you're not okay are you
gonna live your life according to their
insecurities are you gonna continue
being the hottest [ __ ] alive
um okay this is i had this conversation
with someone today i don't think
saying
i am hot makes me hot
i don't
you can walk around with your head up
shoulders back
and
it's not gonna make you hotter i mean
especially as a girl guys are very
visual that might help to get females
i'm sure
but for men
let me know in the comments i could be
wrong [ __ ]
why the [ __ ] are people so [ __ ]
stupid
like i take better care of myself now
than i did when i was smaller this is so
wrong on so many levels
just do you
the only exception i can think of is
when i was 15 i used to have
a pop and a cookie for breakfast and i
was very skinny because
my poor choices did not catch up to me
yet and they eventually did
and now i don't do that anymore but
over the age of maybe 21
if you're bigger
you're eating more it's not
it's not crazy just because someone is
thin does not mean they take care of
themselves
and vice versa like get the [ __ ]
that's true that's true there are skinny
people that are unhealthy too that's
true
[ __ ]
i'm fat i'm fat you came in my pages to
tell me that but i love me and i love my
snacks you insecure baby that's so whack
don't worry about me get help with that
[ __ ] i'm confident
i'm fat i'm fat you came to my page just
to tell me that but i love me and i love
my snacks you insecure baby that's so
whack don't worry about me get help with
that [ __ ] i'm confident
i wouldn't even be confident enough to
do that myself
that's all i'm gonna say
[ __ ] i got news the fat is already here
[Music]
that's crazy
she'd be so pretty if she lost weight
like she has a very very pretty face you
can tell
[Music]
oh my gosh she is huge
and why don't we oh my gosh i had a
conversation with a girl on my team
about this
i said why are we pretending
like
we would be hotter if we gained a
hundred pounds we wouldn't be we would
be less attractive
like why are because i said something to
the to the effect of i was hotter when i
was 20 pounds lighter and she said oh no
daddy i'm like why are you lying to me
you don't have to lie to me
you seriously do not
have to lie to me it's okay
i'm gonna get back there
give me a year i will be back
[Music]
um
hi it's just me a piece of fat art in
front of a fat art wall
um it is so often that fat people put
their pleasure as something that's not
important or something that's seen as
just like negligible and so i just want
to remind all you fat babies out here
that your pleasure is really important
and if you need assistance with getting
that fat pleasure
huh check oh
oh that's too much information
like thin fun
giving me life and you can use my code
angelina for twenty percent off
and trust me good lady you will not
regret it tmi
massive dummy thick thighs
what do you mean i have massive
beautiful dummy thick thighs actually no
one commented that i just know it's true
know you're worth fellas
okay um
that was interesting
no
guys
my webcam how long has that been off
what the hell sorry guys um let me know
in the comments if you guys agree or
disagree with that video don't forget to
subscribe i'll talk to you guys next
time